no ho preso ho preso l'altro perché
perché ho preso l'altro ragazzi quanta
nostalgia c'è in questo video happy with
episodio 1 sempre stessa faccia stesso
armadio che è lo stesso ma i capelli no
grazie a dio per tutti ragazzi bene e
sono io sono felice di 151esimo episodio
perché sono tanti ma questo è speciale
perché sto ritornando sui livelli fatti
quelli meglio tutto il mondo su queste
sono questi qua che l'ultima volta non
ti avevo fatti l'ultima touch è stato lo
speciale quindi oggi gli facciamo a
apple shooter iniziamo con questo sono i
veli questi sono i fatti veramente bene
e sono i fatti farci una volta ogni
tanto sta roba perché meritano
vediamo come siamo arrivati alla apple
shooter beccare il tipo va bene vado
credo di avergli sparato nel punto più
sbagliato però non fa niente
provo girato perché va parabola capito
un casino faccio abbastanza schifo
scusami e mo mo so al millimetro è ecco
è un pelino più sopra era meglio fa bene
raga non potete farmi fare sti livelli
difficili però è l'unico poi o meno male
si è salvato carattere lescot viva
l'ungheria in qualche modo pubblicità
avanti comunque che sarà un livello
incredibile string a love story di io by
io sono tuo marito va bene proviamoci
poi vedere cosa si tratta amico mio che
senso io sono tutto marito spiegami
cos'è sta roba
m.it ha posto una storia d'amore in che
senso ha la storia d'amore se ci sono
luke non deve esserci quindi devi
toglierti prima cosa è tutto a posto va
bene
diamo non ho capito ma è un livello
stranissimo you love me no non ti amo
perchè non ti ho vista ancora è va bene
ti amo basta che stai calma non ti ho
vista ancora
quindi non so come sei di persona
potresti non so parlare farmi un
discorso per vedere come la pensi almeno
mi innamoro non so da che parte di qua e
non si apre equipaggio clicco mi sta
indicando la strada sbagliata sei
stupido
innanzitutto partiamo sei maschio
femmina questo è importante ma ragazzi
non si riveli incredibile show dei
disegni incredibili ma cosa succede ma
chi l'ha fatto
non ho capito che nel senso della storia
d'amore in tutto questo però va beh non
approvo il mio romanticismo ripetitivo
può grazie
non ho capito niente di quello che ho
appena giocato pre bello o il portale
della libertà sono alcuni sopravvissuti
ci hanno fatto ad arrivare a portare
della libertà sei tu uno di loro
vediamo mamma mia ragazzi diventa sempre
un asse a giocarsi livelli no non ancora
tu ma chi è
welcome to work a vacca non si chiamava
orca vacca a livello però mi sono cagato
addosso
rifacciamo devo arrivare al portale sì
ma è un casino ragazzi mi rendete conto
che sono in bici e lo stavi ci vai agli
1 allora luca pento perfetto occhio e un
jump square
e vabbè adesso vivo
tutto è bene quel che finisce bene ma
diamo a il portale quello che appena
attraversato fighissimo sulla luna orca
vacca ok frontflip tutto bene non sarà
che dove sto andando
no no no no no no no no no via via via
via scusami potesse evitare di lasciar
di lanciarmi delle asce però va bene lo
stesso portale 6 sembra una novità ora
cava h stiamo tutti i cani è uno o
roscoe demonio che e vabbè sono l'acqua
vivo
guarda figlio e poi da mar mio figlio è
morto un'ora fa orco demonio smettetela
di lanciarmi faccine ok hai vinto è però
smettila di spingermi ho vinto non è
sicuro e dipende se mi riesca a tirar su
che non è mica detto ce l'ho fatta bene
non ho più la mano ma va bene chi
sarebbe a chi servono mano e portalo
freedom è stato carino segway ball nuova
intelligenza artificiale in che senso
non far sì che la palla tocchi o parte
ok quindi manda la palla dall'altra
parte e se la fa rimbalzare i vinto e
carina segue hai perso va bene jump into
stato e ho capito che devo far passare
la palla da parte bello e tipo un po una
pallavolo un po più hardcore po più
grossa poteva all'asta palla ma che
figata
ma tipo come fa l'avversario muoversi
come mondo mi muovo io l'intelligenza
artificiale vera hanno fatto un
intelligenza artificiale su happy with
two sorella controllo di palla becca
testa schiacciata vinto dopo aver mai
fortissimo che stefano scusami orca
vacca zaytzev non ha veramente ragazzi
impossibile suo livello
smettila smettila non è vero mi ha
fregato da explorersweb ma facebook ma
mi sa che avversario incredibile ha
velocemente temi avversari del mio
calibro
c'è gente fortissima con la scusa come
faccio a vincere una botta incredibile o
ragazzi veramente impossibile vincere la
partita
a meno che non non mi sta chi la segue
il processo che si è vista coperto mi
devo staccare attaccarmi alla palla
teoricamente questo potrebbe essere un
tentativo perché se non riesca a vincere
impossibile porca vacca ce l'ho fatta
maledizione aveva sbagliato alla prova
fare no sono vivo a posto mi sono
staccato vediamo se vinco ho perso o
parto subito in schiacciata tipo così
maledizione da ritirare però si era
gliela porca vacca quanto è difficile
sto gioco
no no veramente in pre credo sia in
positivo
dai dai non puoi vincere non ci credo
che non ci voglio credere
no regalo ha preso come la ripresa come
la ripresa come la ripresa la riprende
velino no mancata
io no ragazzi impossibile come faccio a
noi non me ne vado di qui finché non
l'ho battuto anche se non si può battere
perché teoricamente si può abbattere si
deve battere questo qui
sì perché c'è scritto che un'intesa
tipici alemanno non vuol dire che non lo
puoi battere occhio maledizione
devo fargli i tiri bassi proprio quelli
che lui non capisce neanche 2 che sta
facendo capito così maledizione rami
sono fregato solo occhio perfetto ma dai
bar code monia ora con te lo sei
meritato st pedata in faccia
occhio
[Musica]
sono stato un ora tentare di batterlo
mio dio north pole rush buon natale 2011
a tutti che phil sono solo passati
quegli otto anni però va bene va bene
viva babbo natale suisse sa che quel
avevano appena aggiunto la boe natale
che mi pare non ci fosse subito un elfo
mi è andato già [ __ ] fa niente
ma niente fa niente babbo usa n'è uno
solo
time to fly space ecco però mi devi dire
che sono i coltelli a posto babbo vai
vai sei da solo ma fa niente
we try again che noi stiamo adesso dove
devo andare
no maledizione spiegatemi dove dovrei
arrivare in tutto questo o salve gli
attacchi tu beh mi sono lanciato perché
meritava bello suo livello carino non è
natale ma fa niente benvenuto ad ep city
cioè dovrebbe dovrebbe essere buongiorno
c'è una lamborghini laboratorio ei nice
to meet you might uniti youtube c'è la
tavola periodica di ieri wheels va bene
permesso
fatemi vedere cosa dovrei fare il suo
livello salve proveremo una macchina del
tempo che abbiamo appena costruito va
bene nonno non sono molto fiducioso però
ok sto fermo ma è tipo stranger king's
qua che si aprono i portali radar che
dark e come dark altri soggetti
siamo tornati nel 1800 785 milioni di
anni dopo
va bene mi sa che non è proprio èperché
sexy il futuro il futuro sa di pi greco
è un livello in 3d la madonna quanto ho
fatto bene
hanno fatto livello in 3d tutto questo
ottimo sono caduto nel continuum spazio
temporale bola vabbè rovello strano ma
bello helicopter rampage mi sa che
ospita ma non pensavo fosse con l'uomo
elicottero invece non solo come un
elicottero va bene non ho mai capito
come faccio a lanciare i missili ma li
ho lanciati non sono solo non so come ho
fatto però lo fa store
non fatemi domande regali
tranquilli tutto bene
tutto a posto un povero space bossi qua
mi scusi ma fascino che non hanno fatto
più difficile mi sta mettendo a dura
prova ragazze però proviamo ci vai
ci credo credo in me stesso ok
ma come ho vinto è successo boh ho vinto
però l'importante convinto e banana pil
salve otto sono stati a lecce la buccia
di banana desktop tranquillo l'ho vista
a luke anziché si guarda a paliano
aprire una buccia di banana
prendi la prima che qualcuno si faccia
del male va bene va bene sta zitto cioè
vedi che lo insulta anche nei livelli
normale figlio cioè non sono solo di
insulto luke potuti vissuta cosa dove tu
cos'è sto dove si è finiti tutto questo
è partito da una buccia di banana usa un
horror salve gli abbandoni dei quartieri
you che però va bene niente né avanti
ragazzi il laboratorio segreto
non so il mondo andato alla ricera pò
calisse con la buccia di banana tutto
questo è mi spiegate cosa sto vedere
perché ci sono foto di donne nude sa
cosa sia un giocare sull ve passano da
vecchio ho aspettato un sacco di tempo
per incontrarti non ho tempo di spiegare
does not like to explain che le porterò
dire trasportare indietro nel tempo a
quale la pistola dvd con fiuti sta
indietro ma è nei rottami sono e sono
qui devo mettermi aia ecco ma manoa
troppo indietro ma chi sei è questa qua
è una bicicletta tra le insegne o
malizia ne sono nell'epoca sbagliata
va bene verso le braccia in tutto questo
noi sbagliato epoca però fa niente
queste parti
era una buccia di banana la partenza di
suo livello e non so se vorrei ricordare
mio dio
eccoci non mi tocca luke la prendi tu
quest area 3000 bastonato copione papa
fermati
ho vinto non stai zitto dopo un posto
casinò ho bisogno di leggere dei libri
di storia per poter far ritornare il mio
cervello come era prima ragazzi spero
che il video vi sia piaciuto non saprei
descrivere cosa ho appena gioco però è
pv se un bel gioco è questo non vi prego
non dite niente alla prof di storia di
quello che avete visto perché non saprei
spiegarmi da una buccia di banana
derivano grandi responsabilità volo
sappiamo tutti vado a mangiare una
banana nel frattempo lasciate mi piace
al video iscrivetevi al canale
schiacciate la campanella per ivan
aggiornati sui video che escono come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
belle ragazze
[Musica]